costa deixou a piraí a rima piraí
eu estava e me da minha terra pequena
terra fazendo jardim marília jardim um
pequeno trator
eu recebia uma ligação do amigo da piraí
é locação de veneza piraí primeira vez a
visitar piraí
o que eu conhecia piraí a ser mais de
dez anos foi inventado bateria muito
trabalho nunca teve a oportunidade de
visitar piraí
eu decidi que esta é a oportunidade da
avenida iraí onde estava piraí e uab a
windows 8 é falar de piraí com muito
contato e obteve assim como a noite de
interessar
quando eu desci pt na cidade pequena
muito olímpia muito organizada com uma
sensação muito tranquila de
tranquilidade a proximidade da gente é
muito tranquila e uma desculpa por meu
portunhol e eu é tratar de fazer
entender
primeiro ele é de agradecer ao comitê de
meus amigos de piraí
eu penso que eu recomendo a história foi
uma pequena parte da história da piraí
paty uma pequena garrafa família
eu quero compartilhar com o zé se na
experiência de minha apresentação
comparada eu estava escutando a
palestrante seu cuidado
obviamente empatado o conteúdo das
palestras a qualidade das mensagens e eu
queria apresentar um pouco nas coisas do
passado que coisas pensamos 19 anos
atrás do piraí digital e começou a a
surgir
então na minha apresentação bater nessa
orientação que com só pensávamos das
cidades digitais poucas cidades digitais
haja deixar nervoso quando eram os focos
e quais são as questões importantes para
começar eu me lembro de huh na uma
pequena história do amigo relacionada
com um concerto da inovação tecnológica
hoje e amanhã
muita gente falou da inovação é esta
história é dizia 1907 simultaneamente
dois pessoas acudiam estados unidos ao
mandante da bancária para conseguir
financiamento para suas idéias se
simultaneamente uma pessoa se chamava
regime for que queria fabricar carros
muitos carros de uma maneira repetitiva
viciante e outra havia acidente chegou
mesmo a entidade bancária outra pessoa
george morrison perdendo também o
dinheiro ajuda econômica para ampliar
seu negócio de ferraduras para salvá los
estou mega a pensar como estas duas
pessoas tenha dois visão aos diferentes
e tudo que passar tempo para o impacto
destas duas pessoas que cá simultânea e
mãos com o mesmo objetivo para
desenvolver suas idéias inovações ao
time dá uma também retira de tempo para
ver o impacto da inovação não é imediato
demonstra a associação o problema era
como internet que aparece como uma
ferramenta revolucionária e aparecia
também o ponto certo de si
sociedade da informação pode canalizar
se atualizar postar ao ciudadano normal
pela rua da pequena comunidade local que
podemos fazer para acelerar a total é
tempo para que é esse cidadão da pm pois
aproveitar as vantagens desta nova
ferramenta
e aí nascia o concerto de por que não
pensar é uma comunidade pequena
comunidade local onde todos os cidadãos
divinos olhar nossa tarefa do trabalho
na semana nos seus filhos
morávamos registro civil a buscar o nada
essência para produzir temos compramos
uma pequena apartamento
ele quer registrar temos educação nas
escolas
vamos visitar o avô tom que podemos
fazer para transformar na cidade e que
se a benefícios para a maior parte da
população como jeová
esta nova ferramenta a maior parte de
gente
a maior parte dos cidadãos o tempo mas
corta o possível socorro o projeto que
demonstrava pensamento
plantamos entrou no seu conceito de
cidade digital
michaela se esta informação aparecia há
dez anos estimava-se de janeiro
pela informação que um uma pessoa de
north américa que ele aproximadamente 70
anos o wii amplamente superado que tenha
acesso à televisão a livros a cinema
periódicos jornais rádio internet e
equivalia a 6 gigabytes de código afi a
quantidade de informação de uma pessoa
de 70 anos norte américa se está cálculo
senhor leste seja generalizada a toda a
humanidade e pensamos que todas as
pessoas do mundo mina 70 anos promédio
então da informação acumulada na mente
das pessoas de toda a humanidade 1.200
petabytes de dados
no total mais de diversas maneiras
portanto por cada vai ter armazenado na
memória humana e outros 10 está
armazenado na memória humana muita muita
informação internet informação e
sociedade da informação venda mais nossa
primeira objetivo nossa primeira tarefa
como faz há anos a tecnologia da
informação comunicação era muito
estendido 11 termina um pouco confuso
que a mídia diferentes interpretações
falar genericamente da tecnologia da
informação e comunicação
realmente
internet como as chegadas no benefício
de entender a sociedade a nossos
políticos
à noite os administradores a nossos
líderes sociais e empresariais
é um tema de princípio de que se na
questão
naquele então se saberá se há dez anos
nós pensávamos que latino américa em
todo o seu conjunto como um todo nós
fazemos as seguintes perguntas
entendendo a situação de latinoamérica
hoje as designers nós podemos pode
inserir uma latina américa que não
utiliza a internet para gerar a levar
saúde atuam nos pontos pequenos a todas
as comunidades da latin américa é muito
difícil eu mesmo me agecom um grupo de
voluntários a venezuela a orinoco na
selva pequeno avião chegaram budô a dar
zero hora em cannon o rio mas é uma
comunidade indígenas
lá eu vi uma pequena antena conectada um
centro no hospital da capital e e como
estes voluntários ajudavam a doutores
médicos jovens ajudava a comunidade
indígena a tratar enfermidades como a
malária com a ajuda dos terminais da
internet na internet quando eu é o
pessoalmente ver essa realidade a
compreender a importância dessa
ferramenta
portanto eu dizia como podemos também
educar a milhões de pessoas
esses jovens com o limitante espaço
físico da universidade existem na
américa latina com as escolas que
existem juntas a projeção de popular
tal como podemos fazer sem na internet
muito difícil
a internet também vai jogar um papel
muito importante na educação o que penso
que a itália está descansando em face da
educação e gerar emprego ou de novo para
a gente pensar também elogia o trabalho
das possibilidades de trabalhar através
da internet
dez anos pode estender esta ferramenta
na internet para as oportunidades a todo
o território não somente as cidades
grandes
conectadas com melhor infraestrutura
quando em muitas comunidades latino
américa olhar densidade de população
a baixa qualidade dos serviços
diferente da grade quatro grandes temas
infraestrutura infraestrutura a todas
estas comunidades um grande tema
infraestrutura a pessoa necessita há um
ano hoje inteligente terminais e hoje
superou em pouco tempo toda a
expectativa que hoje os terminais e
integra a área de inteligência
entre as muitas diferentes funções e não
se pensava na se desejarmos algumas
figuras que nós malharam utilizávamos
então as designers do modelo de cidade
digital na internet para todo vai também
para empresas para o cidadão passa isso
eletrônicos para a justiça
o turismo ea agricultura é o modelo
partenon e síria são os designers cena
muito populares se deixarmos o projeto
da cidade digital estratificado na parte
promotores públicos privados e da
parceria público privada dos usuários
cidadãos empresas e administrações
empregar empregados
jamieson eletrônica nas apresentações da
cide sobre conteúdos dos meios de pagão
telecentros
tudo está sem calças que tratando-se
estrutural e conhecimento que existia de
janus da cidade digital está estamos ao
lado de modelos de carro desce designers
para nos entender e é outra
característica também da cidade digital
dessas dez anos serão promovidas desde
lá municipalidades por coletivos há
meses vinculados ligados à
municipalidade mas necessitava que não
foi a soja iniciativa de um grupo de
pessoas individuais que a mulher alguma
conexão uma institução na
institucionalização
por isso vira e digital nos parecia uma
maneira adequada
quando nós estudamos em caso de piraí
que é uma cidade digital acompanha a
ciclo de vida do cidadão se adapta às
suas necessidades
2 criança quando as pessoas crescem
compreender as necessidades de cada
grupo social na cidade é pequeno o
brasil tem complexidades integrar as
distintas necessidades grupos sociais
oferecer serviços de qualidade
fomentar a atividade econômica também a
importância da economia na estabilidade
e equilíbrio dinamizar a vida pública se
preocupa com a qualidade de vida da
região entre comunidade e permite
participar os próprios cidadãos em
desenvolvimento futuro da cidade e
também está está digital dando a
importância que vai jogar na tecnologia
móvel esta evolução a território
inteligente evolução natural
assim pensava há 10 anos a concluir
nós pensamos para compartilhar novas
experiências para ser frente juntos a
este desafio importante trabalhar juntos
compartilhar experiências e encontrar um
lugar comum para dialogar para
harmonizar a linguagem da fama de falar
para 1 104 argentina mesmo para para mim
mesma palavra significa diferentes
diferentes linguagens
também nesse espírito de cooperação
ibero-americana da cidade digital em
2007 havia mais de 3.500 municípios
integrados para compartilhar
experiências
integrados para com o certo é você podia
clicar neste portal
essa lei imediatamente ao portal
municipal de mais de três mil pequenos
municípios de latino américa do sul na
revolução movimento de cooperação para
fazer chegar os benefícios da internet a
macio daninha as comunidades locais e
finalmente um reconhecimento porque eu
estava aqui em 2004 o prêmio para
estimular a inovação pela cidade de
download e piraí foi escolhido por um
grupo internacional despertos para ser
merecedor desse projeto piraí digital eu
prazo para piraí
esse é um link de minha trabalho uma
cidade de piraí é mais satisfatório para
mim
hoje eu estou aposentado e se comprovar
que aí muitos amigos e quando não fazem
trabalho e trabalhou 0 operativo de
fraternal eu deixa uma coisa muito boa
que só os amigos das amizades que nunca
passa é sempre sair então eu queria
agradecer novamente a meus amigos e
piraí do lecce todo mundo e finalmente
na quarta provocação
eu o vejo tão impressionado a palestra
de dória 83 provocações
esta manhã na quarta provocação aberta
provocação s
eu visto dispensado refletir no que tem
muitas coisas positivas não há dúvida
mas também tem coisas que não podem
vacilar isolar 11 óbitos
salada internet das roças milhões de
conexões
eu gostaria fazendo a provocação de
fazer compatíveis na internet
um abraço em contato físico não se pode
substituir nada quando o novo amigo
pessoalmente quando o povo para te uma
alegria uma jóia diferente
eu gostaria de ver a minha a provocar
saúde porque não fazem na internet e na
raça na internet abraço terá ido à
provocação
em finalmente gostaria de ver a raiva
piraí bona sorte tem muitos animados no
sexo
obrigado